blue light cab podcast man special
guests in here my guys from tampa yeah
yeah we're here baby gotta welcome
my guy richie west young dread ytc in
the building watson we're outside
hey man real quick before we have y'all
you know get your [ __ ] off like uh what
well first of all it's good to see y'all
man it's good to see y'all uh we've been
knowing each other for
probably eight years now i think i first
met you in 2014 when i moved to tampa
you guys been making noise for a very
long time
um what just fill in everybody i know
you're on tour with smoke purp right now
but music wise what's going on with
y'all
yeah i got the album out right now last
laugh
um
it dropped in january you're just
constantly dropping music staying
consistent man even during the pandemic
man we was active
and uh this is the first u.s tour that
we did since uh the covid so now we we
back outside yeah we outside man stars
born out right now featuring the homie
little baby hot boy smoked purple y'all
go run that [ __ ] up man we outside baby
you guys doing another joint album soon
because if people don't know you guys
are brothers right right yeah brothers
blood brothers they know like yo that's
my brother no like y'all ain't no cat
[ __ ] it's real like saying mama daddy so
is there gonna be another joint album
yeah we actually working on that uh part
three yeah part three man so we we
dropped two installments of it my
brother and me and now we're going three
and you know thirty three charms yeah
look forward before the year is over for
real there it is man well let's let's go
crazy man play that beat cook
oh
we in here now
we're here with kev turn me up a little
piece
look
i ain't no regular rapper i'm a
certified trapper could have been a ups
man i'm serving the package taking
flight i'm taking risks could've took
his [ __ ] too cause i took his [ __ ] yo
i'm from where it's sunny but it get
bloody trigger city [ __ ] now they can't
take it from me nah i got that 40 in my
pocket shooting shot storyakovich i
ain't playing games pop up on them watch
these [ __ ] glitch ballin with the gang
got a lot of points a lot of sits 30 on
my left wrist i guess i'm that lit bases
in the trap going broke cause they need
a fix i already seen a meal before i
seen a deal 40 yard dash to the racks we
still in the field [ __ ] ain't learned
yet and i ain't teaching either [ __ ]
slept on me huh it's double for the
future i don't owe you [ __ ] i don't know
you i don't know your mama you was in
the trap with me cooking like it's benny
hotter yeah they try to lock us up
trenches know i'm still in touch try to
tell my youngest chill but they still
spin it still ice cream rocks in the
watch look like dippin dots i ain't
really got no option [ __ ] boys don't
want a box put some red beans on his
body like some chicken pox
[Music]
i was trapping in the hallway i ain't go
to class touchdown in the city gotta get
a pass all them gangsters and the
robbers gonna be on your ass if we
running up you know we gonna push them
back all the candidates gonna flash like
a photograph
[ __ ] think they know but they don't
know they have you could try to add it
up but you don't know the math
[Music]
if i step inside the club i prefer to
glock if she ain't got a fat ass i
prefer the top it ain't my fault if a
[ __ ] say he fell out like when them j's
dropped [ __ ] quick to sell out
so don't ask me about what's his name
like lamar said [ __ ] can't stand the
ring i be off the meds like i got a lot
of pain shout out my og pong he gave me
a lot of game taught me how to trout
taught me how to rob like tommy and
martin i ain't have a job gang yo
richie west
young dredd shout out to tampa man
roulette cab show
that was a crazy ass freestyle you know
we drop one every week brought to you by
lrg look check out the brand new lrg
duck down records collab the [ __ ] is gas
they got some crazy gear on the way but
the real important part is if you go to
their website right now l dash r
g dot com put it on the screen
you will get 30 off at checkout when you
use the code bootleg
30
off
of whatever you order at lrg that's a
big [ __ ] chunk of change alright so
go to the website use that promo code
bootleg get 30 off and we got another
freestyle coming next week